and finally new rules since it's St
Patrick's Day let's recognize that as
great a country as Ireland is you can't
really think about the Irish without
thinking about division and I can't help
thinking about us right now when I think
about that
the Irish island is still not whole in
Northern Ireland the part that is still
part of England despite its majority
Catholic population went through a
period where political hatred born of
religion turned into something called
the troubles which meant the hatred got
so bad it could not be contained by the
usual means of disagreement so people
live with bombings and sniping and urban
Warfare what Tucker Carlson calls
sightseeing
in America our warring factions aren't
Catholics and Protestants but that same
level of hatred of authorization is
happening between Democrats and
Republicans we've grown less religious
but that's because politics has become
our religion we used to pray for the
nation now each side prays the other
side doesn't destroy the nation on one
side the Church of woke wants to cleanse
us of our past and on the other The Cult
of trump wants to resurrect it
Trump has often depicted as some kind of
religious Warrior and now he's talking
like an end times religious nun he
speaks about an epic battle against
Sinister forces and says I am your
Warrior I am your Justice and for those
who have been wronged and betrayed I am
your retribution
Jesus thanks Batman
to get any closer to Smite the infidels
you'd have to be standing in a cave with
a collision a cough and a turban
we will expel the warmongers he says we
will drive out the globalists we will
cast out the Communists we will liberate
America from these villains and
Scoundrels once and for all big talk
from a guy who can't even shut up his
girlfriends
[Music]
but that's where we are your fellow
citizens who support the other party
aren't just wrong they're Heretics who
have to be destroyed political
identities have become stronger than
religious ones stronger even than racial
94 of adults are now cool with
interracial marriage it's interparty
marriage that's a deal breaker for a
majority of Republicans and Democrats
who don't want their kids marrying
someone who belongs to the other
America's national leprechaun Marjorie
Taylor green
all right
she didn't invent our country's
polarization any more than she could
spell it but
she's playing with the kind of fire that
made Northern Ireland a living hell for
so long when she says we need a national
divorce we need to separate by Red
States and blue States we're done
and then she threw Biden's things out on
the lawn and said I'll be at my mother's
but a full third of likely voters agree
with her and approve of a national
divorce with Texas the most enthusiastic
66 percent of all voters there are ready
to split including 59 percent of
Democrats
but you know just voicing this idea is
dangerous
because it reinforces the belief that
you can't even talk to those people you
just have to somehow nullify their very
existence by creating a country only of
your type of people it's always such a
tempting thought isn't it if we could
just keep the out
of where we the good people are this
would be such a great place but where do
you draw the line as to how much someone
can disagree with you before they're an
too
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
seemed pretty joined at the hip for a
while they both loved God Guns and gas
stoves
but they reportedly had a bathroom fight
in January of course over a guy Kevin
McCarthy
[Applause]
Marjorie does this that Lauren doesn't
get to live with you now in the new free
republic of Jesus zippy
and what about your own state of Georgia
which has a republican governor and two
Democratic senators what are you going
to do with the two and a half million
Georgia residents who voted for the
Democrats put them on a plane to
Martha's Vineyard
were for gay marriage
does that make them rhinos Republican in
name only and to rhinos get to live with
you in dumbasses Dan
or do they all have to report Deport to
Oklahoma
what about the 11 percent of
conservatives who want strong borders
but think the wall is stupid
what about the 12 percent of Bernie
voters who listed their second choice As
Trump sounds like this new red State
country is going to have to itself split
into two or maybe more since there are
many Republicans who want a legalized
pot
what I call the good ones
and same on the blue side I assume
abortion won't just be legal in Newsom
land but encouraged
what about the 25 percent of Democrats
who oppose abortions what I call the bad
ones
or the 28 percent who have a gun
seems like we're going to need a lot
more new countries than just the two
or we could just stick with the one
the one the one
where everybody gets to disagree on
everything except for one thing you have
to want to stay in the marriage
you can't call yourself a patriot of the
United States and not be for the whole
United part
so this same product
so this St Patty's Day let's take that
home we're all Irish on St Patty's Day
thing and replace it with we're all
Americans every day